so one of the big things that uh i saw
people all day pretty much on twitter uh
when you guys announced the campaign
they were like look maybe chris is right
maybe they're not who knows but why
don't they just fork the bitcoin code
and allow the market to decide what was
the thought process in terms of running
the campaign versus just going and
forking the code making any changes that
you thought or the rest of the group
thought would be applicable and then
allowing the market to decide what was
valuable
well first of all i'm not that smart and
i don't have that much energy anymore so
and nobody would trust me to do
something like that so uh no this is
about one awareness let's get awareness
uh of the problem the climate problem
the contribution here and then yeah like
can you inspire like come on let's make
a code change and again a code change
consistent with the values of bitcoin
community but come on i gotta believe
whether it's the core developers who
come up with this whether it's a minors
association hey a smart teenager in
cambodia right a math teacher in the in
ukraine i mean the world can do this
right they can figure this out but we
got to start working on it that's the
only point we're trying to make i can't
do that but there's brilliant people out
there and everybody's dialed into crypto
right now the whole world is so we can
come up with something better
okay
now there was a uh a line in a bloomberg
article that i read uh and the line was
the campaign believes that about 50 key
miners crypto exchanges and core
developers have the power to change
bitcoin's code now as you can imagine
this was probably the one thing in all
of the articles that i saw people
getting the most worked up about uh i
saw everything from like who are the 50
people right to uh how do you
how do you not include node operators
after we saw the block size wars etc
just
maybe to to kind of uh make this
valuable for folks who are listening how
do you think the code would be changed
do you agree with the statement that
there's 50 miners and exchanges and
people that could do this do you think
that maybe that was a uh overstatement
or just walk me through kind of that the
process of actually changing it if there
was a change that you thought was uh
applicable yeah question i mean go back
to you know there's a book out recently
about the block size wars right and you
look at kind of some of the the the the
battles they're i don't know what you
might call it kind of family dispute in
2015 right i mean you know back then uh
you know if you look some of the medium
posts and kind of what we're supporting
it's like 30 to 50
info it's called influential people
you're right they don't have the power
to unilaterally do anything
but they're influential right so they
got behind something could they convince
other people in the community that we
should hey we gotta do this right uh you
know how to segue you know come about
right that kind of a thing so it's an
influential thing certainly that can
come internally and that would be a look
like a soft fork can come externally and
it could be a hard fork who knows that's
you know hopefully that doesn't go that
way but um
these things can be done you're right
they're
they're they're not you know it's it's
uh
kind of messy right but um but again
if it's in the interest of the community
these things can be done
and change is a good thing sometimes
right i get it concert being
conservative
is important when you talk about finance
but these are cutting ed tech technology
where the very beginning is it's like 13
years in why are we stopping innovating
right now doesn't make sense
you can do better
as a related point to this how do you
think about the importance of node
operators especially in a decentralized
system like bitcoin and having the
checks and balances between the
developers the miners the node operators
like what the role of the node operators
which obviously they played a crucial
role in the outcome of what happened the
block size wars how do you think about
their importance in something like this
is that the the key group to go and
convince uh to get a change push through
or what
yeah i mean it depends what their role
is right are they in exchange or just
you know somebody with an interest in
the network right so probably in
exchange probably goes along with their
customers right of fidelity for example
say hey look we've got to get on this
new code base because this improves uh
the climate situation that might be
influential to one validator if it's
just a validator let's say hey we're
just going to hold a line we're never
going to change and that's a different
com you know that's a different
calculator calculus but it is very
important right because they can reject
uh you know something that might happen
from that that core group um you have to
convince them you have to it's
influencing them and and motivating them
that this is a positive and not not
something that's going backwards uh one
of the other themes was basically uh the
conversation that you've had have you
talked with exchange ceos have you
talked with the black rocks the
fidelities etc what has been their
reaction if you have spoken to them uh
what any insights there
yeah i mean i don't want to you know
actually name names that wouldn't be
appropriate but we have spoken with a
number of folks including minors and
what some minors are doing are being
really responsible you know you look at
argo and
riot and giffon
they're doing the right thing with the
renewables the problem is the code
doesn't say anything about renewables
right the code just says
incense
cheap energy right so the saudis say
we're getting in the mining tomorrow all
those taxes they all the mining going on
texas move over to saudi arabia with
saudi arabia and be fossil fuels and
it'd be super cheap right so i mean some
people
uh get it right and have said that um
but i get it this is a controversial
thing it's a big step
but look we're in unchartered waters
here with climate crisis and we got to
be fighting this thing on every single
front and it's one of the fronts hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time